Richard David Precht hat für eine Menge
Aufregung gesorgt der Fernseh Philosoph
hat erst bei uns im ZDF ein zwei
Interviews zu China geführt und jetzt
sehen wir dass die erfolgreichste
Wirtschaftsnation der Welt und dann hat
ein Podcast mit Markus Lanz richtig vom
Leder gezogen gegen die grüne
Außenministerin Anna Lena baerbock und
besonders gegen ihre China-Politik die
er ganz falsch findet dass ich immer
denke was für ein Unfall dass diese Frau
Außenministerin geworden ist tatsächlich
reden im Moment einige DDR Brecht
behauptet dass wir in Sachen China den
Ball mal ganz flach halten sollten und
vielleicht denkt ihr ja auch dass wir
viel zu sehr von China abhängig sind
dass das der Burg in Peking so die
Backen auf blasen könnte und China vor
einem Angriff auf Taiwan waren
erst recht gewaltsame Veränderung des
Status quo wäre für uns als Europäer
nicht akzeptabel die Chinesen jedenfalls
waren nordamer News und viele zu Hause
auch nicht neben Brecht auch wichtige
Teile der Kanzlerpartei SPD oder
große Industriekonzerne ich finde
deshalb ist es Zeit deren Argumente mal
genauer anzuschauen ich war fünf Jahre
lang korrespondentes ZDF in Peking und
ich gebe euch fünf Gründe warum Precht
nicht recht hat warum und jetzt kommt
seine Art von China Furcht sogar
gefährlich ist für uns alle sie
gefährdet dass sie eigentlich schützen
will unsere Jobs unseren Wohlstand
unsere Sicherheit
[Musik]
webrecht nicht kennt er schreibt
ziemlich viel quasi jedes Jahr ein Buch
im jüngsten kritisierte er die Medien
und er arbeitet selbst bei den Medien
moderiert dem ZDF eine Gesprächsrunde
und hat mit Markus Lanz den Podcast um
den es hier geht was er in diesem
Podcast sagt und was so hohe Wellen
schlägt ist wichtig nicht weil Brecht
ist sagt sondern weil es für eine
Richtung steht der ich als
hauptstadtkorrespondent gerade häufiger
begegne und die gerade wächst in die
Vergangenheit weiß denn eine Zeit da ist
Deutschland sich einredete China würde
sich mit viel handelt schon irgendwann
auch wandeln und in der die
Außenminister allesamt Männer waren
können wir mal rein dass ich immer denke
was für ein Unfall dass diese Frau aus
Ministerin geworden ist
ja also ich nehme an dass die hätte noch
normal am normalen Bedingungen im
Auswärtigen Amt nicht mein Praktikum
gekriegt frage ich mich natürlich was
genau war jetzt nicht normal dass es
nach der Bundestagswahl eine neue
Regierung gab die Ministerämter besetzt
auch mit Frauen so ist Demokratie aber
lass mal weiter hören warum er bearbox
rede blöd fand man hat als Person ja
nichts an Lebensleistung zu bieten das
ist aus der chinesischen Perspektive
wenn man solche Reden macht wo man China
droht nicht ganz unwichtig
dann kannst Du überlegen wie das auf der
anderen Seite wahrgenommen wird als die
ist das einzige was an der grün ist ist
die Farbe hinter ihrem Ohren dafür hat
recht viel Kritik bekommen und er hat
sich danach gerechtfertigt er sei ganz
sicher nicht frauenfeindlich ein anderer
Punkt aber kam dabei viel zu kurz die
Behauptung so dürfen man nicht mit China
sprechen der SPD-Fraktionsvorsitzende
nicht klagen so ähnlich also noch vor
bärbox China Reise behauptete sie haben
sich ja sehr Aussicht Chinas
undifferenziert auf diese Situation
eingelassen dahinter steckt die
Vorstellung dass Politiker in China ihr
Gesicht waren müssten dass man Kritik
also nur im Gespräch unter vier Augen
äußern solle aber bitteschön doch nicht
öffentlich ich glaube das ist China
Kitsch und falsch in meiner Zeit in
China habe ich erlebt Chinesen können
sehr direkt sein umgekehrt und das ist
wichtig akzeptieren sie das auch nur ein
Beispiel als der damalige
Bundespräsident Joachim Gauck im März
2016 zu Besuch in Peking war bereiteten
wir Fernsehteams uns im Konferenzraum
eines Hotels auf ein Interview mit ihm
vor während wir warteten finde die
chinesische Staatssicherheit das waren
Männer in Zivi plötzlich an die Ausweise
unserer chinesischen Mitarbeiter zu
kontrollieren die waren deshalb total
eingeschüchtert und verschreckt
Pressesprecher der deutschen Botschaft
bekam das mit und ging die chinesische
Stasi frontal an er zeigt auf eine Leist
den Boden die den Raum von Nebenraum
abtrennt und sagte laut
sie ist Deutschland das da drüben China
sie sollten gefälligst in China bleiben
der Pressesprecher übrigens war für
prechtsverhältnisse auch noch
vergleichsweise grün hinter den Ohren
aber die chinesische Stasi hörte auf ihn
und zog sich zurück auch Markus Lanz hat
den Podcast übrigens ein bisschen
Bauchschmerzen bei press China Klischee
dass man sich zurückhaltend
sehr gutes Buch was ich auch du das
kennst die neue Erfindung der Diktatur
Kollege von der Süddeutschen der lange
china-korrespondent war der feierte
Annalena baerbock und sagt höchste Zeit
dass einer mal klar redet weil das tun
die Chinesen ihrerseits auch das fand
ich interessante
das ist eine gute Idee fragen wir den
doch mal selbst er war für die
Süddeutsche Zeitung insgesamt 14 Jahre
lang China korresponden denn ein Teil
der Zeit haben wir zusammen Peking
verbracht sein Buch die neu Erfindung
der Diktatur nennt die Washington Post
eins der wichtigsten Sachbücher des
Jahres 2020
so mal gucken Kai Richard David Precht
sagt so kann man mit China überhaupt
nicht reden es sei zum fremdchen gewesen
wie bärbock das gemacht habe und habe
deutschen Interessen überhaupt nicht
gedient stimmt das aus deiner Sicht das
ist ja oft großer Unsinn und ich finde
was Anna-Lena baerbock da gemacht hat
war tatsächlich
weniger moralisches missionieren das ist
wirklich
höchstens die Hälfte nicht mal die
Hälfte sondern sie hat tatsächlich
unsere Interessen vertreten wir haben
ganz neues China gegenüber und das ist
ein China das mittlerweile versucht die
Welt zu verändern es versucht auch ja so
ein bisschen früher hieß es immer die
USA wollten die Welt sicher machen für
die Demokratie jetzt haben wir plötzlich
in China das versucht gemeinsam mit
Russland die Welt sicher zu machen für
die Autokratie und das kann überhaupt
nicht in unserem Interesse sein und da
geht's überhaupt nicht um Konfrontation
sondern geht einfach darum ganz klar
rote Linien aufzuzeichnen so
liebeskina wir schützen jetzt auch uns
selbst darum geht es am Ende vor allem
im Moment danke wir sprechen gleich noch
weiter aber fürs erste können wir uns
merken man muss weder alt und übrigens
auch kein Mann sein um gegenüber
wirklich deutlich zu werden
[Musik]
recht wünscht sich trotzdem eine andere
Art von Außenminister einen der leiser
spricht und nicht nur er wünscht sich
das sondern mindestens auch Teile der
SPD denke ich gerne an Frank-Walter
Steinmeier zurück der das hatte und den
ich einen ausgezeichneten Außenminister
davon so und da wird sie jetzt besonders
interessant weil selbst Steinmeier also
der heutige Bundespräsident sieht den
damaligen Außenminister Steinmeier viel
kritischer als Precht das tut jedenfalls
räumte in Bezug auf die Russlandpolitik
heute ein mit dem Wissen von heute war
die Unterstützung von 19
2014 nach der Annexion der Krim ein
Fehler oder eine Fehleinschätzung
Steinmeier und natürlich auch Angela
Merkel sind wesentlich verantwortlich
dafür dass Deutschland sich so
unglaublich abhängig gemacht hat von
Russlands Gas und Öl und dass wir dafür
jetzt seinen hohen Preis bezahlen
[Musik]
haben wir daraus nichts gelernt was
machen wir mit unserer Abhängigkeit von
China die noch viel weitergeht und noch
viel gefährlicher ist lass mal hören was
Brecht dazu sagt wenn wir irgendwann die
Brücken gar zu China abbauen würden dann
würde unsere Wirtschaft mehr oder
weniger den Bach runtergehen und zwar
ziemlich gewaltig und dann würden unsere
westlichen Werte erst recht keiner mehr
ernst nehmen
die Logik ist nur wer wirtschaftlich
stark ist kann mit seinen Werten
überzeugen so ähnlich sieht das auch der
konservative Flügel der SPD der
Seeheimer Kreis er warnt vor einer Anti
china-strategie ein abruptes Ende der
Handelsbeziehungen mit China wäre ein
ökonomisches Desaster wir sind für die
Sicherheit der heimischen Arbeitsplätze
verantwortlich naja ich kenne jetzt
niemanden nicht mal bei den Grünen der
oder die den Handel mit China abbrechen
möchte das Problem ist genau umgekehrt
Deutschlands Abhängigkeit von China sind
in den letzten zwei Jahren noch mal
enorm gestiegen Audi Volkswagen BMW
Bosch und BFF investieren Milliarden in
China es hätten sie aus dem Russland
disaster nichts gelernt selbst das
Arbeitgeber nein Institut der deutschen
Wirtschaft in Köln befürchtet deshalb
das Zitat Firmen sich auf eine
staatliche Rettung verlassen und deshalb
zu hohe Risiken eingehen wenn es wie im
Falle Russland schiefgeht drohe Zitat
das Verluste am Ende sozialisiert werden
nach dem Gewinne zuvor privatisiert
worden heißt du und ich wir alle brechen
dann Volkswagen und Co sind einfach
so wie bei den Banken der Finanzkrise
aber kann es überhaupt schiefgehen und
[Musik]
ist vielleicht eine komische Frage aber
recht findet nein erstens ist China wenn
man bei ehrlich ist kein komponistisches
Land sondern kapitalistisches Land so
kann Turbo kapitalistisches
landkapitalistische als Deutschland und
wer kapitalistisch ist wird doch nie im
Leben firmend eigenen oder sie zwingen
ihre Betriebsgeheimnisse offenzulegen
oder klar wenn man von China offenbar
nicht viel mehr kennt als die Bilder der
Mega Städte dann kann man auf so eine
abwegige Idee kommen aber lasst uns noch
mal bei einem Nachfragen der China nun
wirklich kennen lasst uns noch mal mit
Kai sprechen was hältst du von der Idee
China ist überhaupt nicht kommunistisch
sondern in Wahrheit nur kapitalistisch
wir dürfen die Natur dieses Regimes
nicht erkennen wir müssen einfach genau
hinschauen sie den pink bringt diese
totale Kontrolle der Partei zurück er
zitiert immer wieder mal mit diesem
Einspruch Mama hat mal gesagt irgendwie
egal ob im Süden oder im Norden im
Westen oder im Osten oder im Zentrum die
Partei beherrscht alles das ist ein
Zitat das hier den Link zum ersten Mal
seit 30 40 Jahren ständig wieder
benutzt er will wieder die totale
Kontrolle der Partei und er hat sie
schrittweise wieder durchgeführt China
behauptet Precht übrigens wolle seine
Werte gar nicht missionieren das sei ihr
der Westen der da seine Werte aufdrücken
will siehst du das auch so in
Wirklichkeit ist es genau andersherum
seit
2013/2014 macht sie den Ping in China
genau das er hat uns nicht nur die
Amerikaner sondern die westliche
Demokratie in internen paar Partei
Publikationen als ideologischen Feind
wiederentdeckt und ich weiß dass es
schwierig ist für uns wir sind es nicht
gewohnt das andere uns als Feind sehen
aber wir hätten doch sehr gut daran
diese Realität einfach anzuerkennen
[Musik]
stattdessen bedrückt Brecht das Säbel
rasseln des Westens ich meine wenn
tatsächlich China Taiwan attackieren
sollte und sich wieder einverleiben ja
wo niemand weiß ob das wahrscheinlich
oder unwahrscheinlich ist das überhaupt
keine einschätzen kann überhaupt keiner
aber wenn sie es tatsächlich tun wird
ich meine dafür würden wir keinen
Dritten Weltkrieg riskieren auch da
steht prächt übrigens nicht allein die
Fraktionsvorsitzenden von SPD und AFD
die sonst wenig gemein haben sehen das
ganz ähnlich dass wir aber nicht
gleichzeitig in ein großmacht-konflikt
zwischen den USA und China kommen das
finde ich schon eine berechtigte Frage
über die wir offen auch diskutieren
sollten ist nicht unsere Frage und liegt
auch nicht im Interesse unseres Landes
und dort einzumängen sollten wir uns
also am besten raushalten und der
rasselt hier eigentlich mit dem Säbel
kein was meinst Du ja auch das ist ja
wieder eigentlich eine Umkehrung der
Tatsachen wenn hier einer mit den sä
rasselt dann ist es ja China also hier
den Ping ist der erste Führer überhaupt
seit Mario dumm seit 50 Jahren der
tatsächlich die Erwartung geschaffen hat
in seinem Volk dass er derjenige sein
wird der Taiwan zurückholen wird ins
Reich und wenn nötig mit Waffengewalt
ich halte im Gegenteil genau richtig das
wie die Annalena baerbock gemacht hat
dass sie nämlich recht nennt das eine
Drohung es ist eine Warnung natürlich
dass ich hier den pink klar macht mir
das auch übrigens andere europäische
Staatsführer gemacht haben dass sich die
Dinge klar macht was für ein Preis er zu
zahlen hätte man nennt das Abschreckung
man nennt das Abschreckung ganz genau
darum geht es das ist das ist wieder
kein moralisieren das ist ein
diplomatisches Mittel seit eh und je
dass man dazu benutzt um andere davon am
Ende abzuhalten zu kriegerischen
Aktionen zugreifen danke dir also fassen
wir mal zusammen wenn wir erstens
glauben dass man aus lauter China Furcht
mit Peking nur fl darf zweitens aus den
Russland Fehlern nichts lernen drittens
unsere Abhängigkeit von China nicht
vermindern sondern sogar noch steigern
uns viertens ein China schönreden dass
es so nicht gibt und nie gab dann
ermutigen wir fünftens am Ende China
dass die Kosten für eine Invasion in
Taiwan schon nicht so groß wären diese
Invasion wäre dann wirklich eine
Katastrophe für Taiwan für Asien für die
ganze Weltwirtschaft und damit nicht
zuletzt auch für uns in Deutschland aber
sagt mir was ihr denkt wie sollen wir
mit China umgehen hat Recht
oder hat er nicht recht